- [Voiceover] What I want
to talk about in this video,
is the notion of Arc Measure,
when we're dealing with circles.
As we'll see, sometimes when you see
something like arc measure,
you might think it's the length of an arc,
but arc length is
actually a different idea.
So we will compare these two things.
Arc length to arc measure.
So arc measure, all that is
is just a fancy way of saying,
if I have a circle right over here,
this is my best attempt
at drawing a circle.
I have a circle here.
The center of the circle,
let's call that point O,
and let me put some
other points over here.
So let's say that this is point A,
let's say this is point B,
and let's say this is
point C right over here.
And let's say that I have,
let's say the central
angle, right over here,
cause it includes the
center of the circle,
so the central angle, angle AOB.
Let's say it has a measure of 120 degrees.
And if someone were to say,
what is the measure of arc AB?
So, let me write that down.
The measure.
So, if someone were to say
what is the measure of arc AB,
and they'd write it like this,
so that's referring to
arc AB right over here.
It's the minor arc, so there's
two ways to connect AB,
you could connect it right over here,
this is the shorter distance,
or you can go the other way around,
which would be what you'd
consider the major arc.
Now, if someone's
referring to the major arc,
they would say arc ACB.
So when you're given just two letters,
you assume it's the shortest
distance between the two.
You assume that it is the minor arc.
In order to specify the major arc,
you would give the third letter,
to go the long way around.
So the measure of arc AB, and sometimes
you'll see it with
parenthesis right over here,
all this is, this is the
same thing as the measure
of the central angle
that intercepts that arc.
Well, the central angle
that intercepts that arc
has a measure of 120 degrees.
So this is just going to be 120 degrees.
Now, some of y'all might be saying,
well, what about the major arc?
Well, let's write that.
So if we're talking about arc ACB,
so we're going the other way around,
so this is major arc.
So what is the measure of arc ACB,
once again we're using three letters,
so that we're specifying the major arc.
Well, this angle, this
central angle right over here,
to go all the way around
the circle is 360 degrees.
So this is going to be
the 360 minus the 120
that we're not including.
So 360 degrees minus 120 is going to be,
is going to be 240 degrees.
So the measure of this angle
right over here is 240 degrees,
so the measure of this arc,
I have to be careful not
to say length of that arc,
the measure of this arc
is going to be the same
as the measure of the central angle.
It's going to be 240 degrees.
These arc measures are
going to be the case
regardless of the size of the circle,
and that's where the
difference starts to be
from arc measure to arc length.
So, I could have two circles,
so this circle right over here
and that circle right over here,
and as long as the central
angle that intercepts the arc
has the same degree measure,
so let's say that that degree
measure is the same as,
these are central angles,
so we're assuming the vertex of the angle
is the center of the circle.
As long as these two are the same,
these two central angles
have the same degree measure,
then the arc measures, then
the corresponding arc measures
are going to be the same.
But clearly, these two
arc lengths are different.
The arc length is not going to depend
only on the measure of the central angle,
the arc length is going to depend
on the size of the actual circle.
Arc measure is only dependent
on the measure of the central angle
that intercepts that arc.
So your maximum arc measure
is going to be 360 degrees.
Your minimum arc measure is
going to be zero degrees.
It's measured in degrees,
not in units of length
that arc length would be measured in.
So, let me write this down.
This only depends...
So, this is what's going to drive this
is the measure of central
angle, central angle,
that intercepts the arc.
That intercepts, intercepts the arc.
When you talk about arc length,
yes, it's going to be
dependent on the angle,
but it's also dependent,
it's going to be dependent
on the measure of that central angle
plus the size of the circle.
Size of the circle.
You're actually talking
about a length now,
when you're talking about arc length.
While here, you're talking
about a degree measure.